so I'm getting a lot of comments like this that are like okay
but what do we do though
and I'm not gonna pretend that I have a step by step plan
for how to overthrow the patriarchy
all I was saying in that last video
is that we're not gonna actually end violence against women by like
creating a “female only” whatever the fuck that means
um society or like
“female separatism” as one of my comments said like
this concept of like
the only way to protect women is to just completely separate women and men
like that doesn't make any sense
but I will tell you with 1,000% certainty
even though I don't have like
a laid out step by step plan
for what we in America can do today to overthrow the patriarchy
I will tell you that as long as capitalism exists um
the patriarchy will also exist
like capitalism is the thing that allows men to oppress women
the class that the gender binary deems to be man
you know and the class that is deemed to be woman
um this is something else
the gender binary like
this whole concept of the gender binary and why
like queer liberation and like
the liberation of women um
these things actually go hand in hand
they're one and the same because the sheer concept of like
the gender binary
the concept of heterosexuality and of being a heterosexual versus a homosexual
like these were all
things that were created to maintain the hierarchy of man over woman
um they were created to maintain this
like nuclear family unit
this traditional system of marriage um
which you know
it's an explicitly Marxist belief that the traditional marriage system is like
a form of like
bourgeois social control anyway
sorry I don't wanna ramble and ramble in this video um
so I'm gonna put on the screen like
a list of like
explicitly Marxist feminist
like anti capitalist feminist readings and um
you guys can leave comments and I can make smaller
shorter videos um
okay bye